this video was done in collaboration
with Dubai World Trade Center for their
future blockchain summit
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
this episode would be an extension of
the last video I did on blockchain it's
becoming increasingly clear that the
technology has massive implications for
almost all aspects of our lives
nothing has shown such wide sweeping
promise since the internet or the latest
generation of AI today we'll be covering
some of the actual projects that are
going on currently that take advantage
of blockchain technology I'm aware that
there's other tech like tangle but
blockchain is the focus of this video
also from here on I want you to
completely forget about their claim
forget about Bitcoin blockchain is so
much bigger than that so this technology
has been called many things the next
stage of the Internet a trustless system
of value and the most important
technology ever invented let's put some
perspective on this but first things
first if you don't know what blockchain
actually is all you need to know is the
following and I'm going to try and avoid
the technical terms here blockchain is a
decentralized transparent and verifiable
system where vely such as ownership
titles medical records and
cryptocurrency can be exchanged this
value is stored in something called a
digital block the blocks are linked
together in such a way that the unique
digital identity of the next block is
linked to the identity of the previous
block hence blockchain
blockchain is shared on a peer-to-peer
network where a continuously updated
ledger keeps track of who owns what
these Ledger's are secured by
mathematics the entire system is
distributed among a network of computers
rather than resting with a single
provider this means that data can't be
tampered with without anyone knowing and
finally there are many different block
chains used for different applications
so to recap blockchain is a distributed
system that's used to exchange value and
can't be tampered with an important
concept to know for this video is the
idea of smart contracts blockchain
enables a new class of apps called Smart
contracts smart contracts basically
replace what people would do with in any
agreement for example say you have two
parties party a and party B that agree
on some terms in a smart contract these
terms are written into code when the
conditions have been satisfied the
contract is automatically executed no
lawyers no company that releases held
funds no disputes no middlemen needed
it's all automatic done exactly as both
parties had defined in the agreement you
can take this idea further and link
smart contracts together to create an
entire company that does things
automatically this is called a
decentralized autonomous organization or
Dao the results eliminates waste reduces
risk of fraud and opens up a whole new
world of automatic systems all right so
now that we're refreshed with the
underlying technology let's take a look
at the impact that this is already
having on the world
let's start somewhere very close to me
the creative video community currently
we have YouTube and twitch but I'll be
focusing on YouTube here YouTube like
most other companies is interested in
profit and that's fine there's nothing
wrong there but the way YouTube is being
managed leads to some incentives that
result in a negative outcome for content
creators and users the two major ones
are as follows number one D monetization
YouTube has to run a fine balance
between satisfying the creators the
people who populate the site's content
and the advertisers those who pay
YouTube for having people watch the
creators content lately YouTube has been
cracking down on content that it finds
might damage an advertiser's brand image
this has led to frustration from content
creators as their revenue streams can
vanish overnight seemingly without
explanation
number two advertising a lot of people
find advertising distracting and a bit
intrusive as advertisers can track your
online behavior well advertising is just
part and parcel of what you have to deal
with with online media or is it there
must be a better way
a few blockchain startups are looking to
create a better system first up we have
view Lee they're providing direct
support for creators through a vote
based tipping system through the
blockchain this cuts out the middleman
another bonus is that view Lee is ad
free because the payments are made
instantly automatically through smart
contracts the payments are carried out
in cryptocurrency tokens which can be
converted into any form of currency that
one wishes duly states that their long
term goal is to evolve into a fully
fledged decentralized autonomous
organization by you Lee not to get
confused with view Lee and flick so are
both similar and run on the etherion
blockchain but in these cases viewers
also get paid to watch line a is another
such project which just successfully
raised twenty million dollars in funding
line o states that they hope to free
creators from the suffocating group of
YouTube revenue sharing agreements terms
and conditions and pay people for
watching content basically if your
content is in high demand you
simple as that no more gatekeepers
flaming viewpoints they don't agree with
project lead Wilson we States quote we
are trying to create a decentralized
autonomous video-content community so we
can cut out the middleman and don't have
the conflict of interest between the
users and the content creators D tube is
yet another blockchain video site but
it's been up and running for over a year
so this is all good and interesting to
see but my worry with this is user
fragmentation initially I think there's
going to be a tussle for which platform
to use but eventually user adoption will
force an equilibrium and the best system
will come out on top also seeing that
the etherion blockchain couldn't even
run crypto kiddies without slowing down
I'll say we're still a ways away from an
etherium blockchain YouTube competitor
but regardless I think that these ideas
are a better way of doing things and
will likely be the future of user based
online video creation and besides other
blockchain such as card I know it could
provide more stability
okay so let's zoom out a little bit and
take a wider look at the impact
blockchain is having so we'll get to the
dizzying array of current blockchain
projects but first let's take a look at
every pedia this is basically a
blockchain version of Wikipedia and it's
more interesting than it sounds i sat
down to have a chat with the co-founder
of Wikipedia Larry Sanger
who was part of the new project
you can think of it as a distributed
database sort of written for the
blockchain essentially so it goes hand
in hand with the blockchain or at least
with the kind of blockchain that we have
which is based on IO CEOs will be one of
the two main content blockchains
platforms I could go on about that for a
long time and there's many different
aspects because there's a lot of
different advantages to the blockchain
but what the blockchain does is it opens
up the possibility of having a truly
credible peer-to-peer network of
encyclopedias again it's open source and
the content is open content but what if
we collect all of those articles or at
least links to all of those articles in
one place and then we make them all
ratable so somebody could go to a page
about Australia right and there's a
dozen articles about Australia there and
you read them through and you give your
rating of each article a bunch of other
people do that the best rises to the top
and the best article according to
everybody in the system is bound to be
pretty darn good but what if the people
who are doing the rating also share
information about themselves your
nationality your politics your religion
your academic specializations your
philosophy whatever and then you could
look at the articles about Australia and
slice them and dice them in different
ways what do the Australians think are
is the best article about Australia what
about the Americans or let's talk about
something more interesting what about
the topic of jihad imagine I don't know
a hundred different articles about jihad
why would there be a hundred because as
soon as this sort of thing is created
there is a competition so sue peep
people start competing to write the best
article so you can imagine the the best
articles according to Saudi Arabians
are according to Libyans Oh what about
according to all Muslims or how about
Muslims who identify as moderate Muslims
or how about Muslims who identify as
traditional Muslims or what about
American conservatives or American
Democrats right you would be able to
compare different points of view on a
topic like jihad and that could
potentially create a huge amount of
understanding that just doesn't exist it
it heightens the level of the
conversation that's the point and
Wikipedia doesn't do it Wikipedia
doesn't allow it they have only one
article about the topic because there's
only one community yes of course it's
possible and people enjoy getting
themselves into bubbles and internet
silos but I think you're not going to be
able to avoid other points of view in
today's world so if you have a
competition to to represent the best
that is known on a given subject now you
have tools to engage in that debate much
much better than you can endure a regime
of fake news and sensationalistic media
of all sorts so restoring global empathy
by making people see things from the
other point of view is absolutely
awesome and very commendable I'm wishing
Larry and the team all the best for this
project all right so let's take a look
at the wider aspects here first
government to buy to buy her set its
sights on becoming the world's first
blockchain powered state in 2016
representatives of 30 government
departments formed a committee dedicated
to investigating the opportunities
across health records shipping business
registration and more it's estimated
that the blockchain will amount to 1.5
billion dollars and savings per year
much of this enhanced productivity will
stem from moving to a paperless
government with a blockchain document
processing removing around 100 million
paper transactions a year Dubai World
Trade Center is actually flying me out
to the future blockchain summit one of
the world's biggest blockchain
conferences
to see what things are really like on
the ground I'll be reporting back
hopefully alive over this channel the
conference is a collaboration between
smart to by a government entity
exploring new technologies and there's a
bio World Trade Center Estonia the
Estonian government has partnered with
Ericsson on a blockchain initiative to
create a new data center where all
public records are stored on the
blockchain South Korea Samsung of course
is creating blockchain solutions for the
South Korean government which will be
put to use in public safety and
transport applications the UK government
is also working on blockchain technology
for pension payments cyber security
guard time is a company trading keyless
signature systems using the blockchain
it is currently being already used to
secure the health records of 1 million
Estonian citizens guard time is also
working with DARPA Lockheed Martin and
Ericsson Healthcare
the company gem is a start-up working
with the Center for Disease Control
they're going to put disease outbreak
data onto the block chain which is hoped
to increase the effectiveness of
disaster relief and response a company
called simply vital health is a couple
of blockchain related projects going on
one of them tracks the progress of
patients after they leave the hospital
and another one provides decentralized
blockchain patient records MIT is
spearheading a project called Meldrick
it's a blockchain project designed to
manage authentication confidentiality
and data sharing of medical records and
is already up and running in Israel
financial services Barclays Bank has
launched a number of blockchain
initiatives involving tracking financial
transactions and combating fraud
Barclays State quote our belief is that
the blockchain is a fundamental part of
the new operating system for the planet
in quote manufacturing and industrial
geocoin India's biggest conglomerate
Reliance Industries has said that is
developing a blockchain based supply
chain logistics platform along with its
own cryptocurrency geocoin transactive
grid is an interesting project based in
Brooklyn that allows members to locally
produce and sell energy the goal is to
reduce the cost involved with energy
distribution the storage dot IO is
distributed and encrypted cloud storage
which allows members to share and used
hard drive space retail open Bazaar is a
company that's attempting to build a
decentralized market where goods and
services can be traded with no middleman
real estate ubiquity is a start-up
that's creating a blockchain driven
system for tracking the completed legal
process which usually creates friction
and expense in the real estate transfer
transport Arcade City is an application
which aims to beat uber at their own
game basically bringing ride-sharing to
the blockchain
so that is just a fraction of what is
going on in the blockchain space it's
becoming clear that a shift is taking
place here some big players can see that
this is a viable option in the future
and I'm getting on board so that they
don't miss out
for example IBM alone is working on 400
different blockchain projects with 63
clients so almost at the end of the
video but one last thing I want to touch
on is who is the biggest winner for
blockchain it's early days but it seems
that blockchains biggest winners will be
those who want to cut out middlemen for
example for information and content
creation services this seems to entail
the Wild West days of the internet where
there was more freedom to see what you
want to see without it being controlled
and moderated by a governing party but
cutting out the middleman there's a lot
further in developing nations
for example blockchain is starting to
take on the task of bridging a poverty
gap around the world with blockchain as
long as you have access to a smartphone
you have a way to conveniently access
money additionally blockchain is a
decentralized system which means that
you don't get charged to transfer money
the way you would with a typical
financial institution the former usually
deters businesses from reaching certain
regions of the world and serving
opportunities for developing countries
for example and this next statistic
shocked me last year the total amount of
cost to send money to sub-saharan Africa
was over 30 billion dollars this is
according to the Bureau of Economic
Analysis so 13 billion dollars in
frictional losses just by having
middlemen a platform called bit Pisa
directly aims to solve this problem
through blockchain technology and I'm
sure there'll be many other projects on
the way so this alone leaving all other
things equal that is the same amount of
money flowing from well-off nations to
poor nations as it is today many tens of
billions of dollars can be generated by
just using blockchain so with that that
rounds out the end of this video let me
know what you guys think about
blockchain
and has this video widen your
perspective a little bit I personally
think that it's very early days but in
the next five to ten years blockchain or
a similar technology will be ubiquitous
let me know your thoughts in the comment
section below this has been - go go
we'll be watching cold fusion and I'll
see you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one cold fusion
are you thinking
[Music]
you